would you advise your students to start
a screenplay without an outline
and just start writing don't worry about
structure so
um i think that you should do whatever
works for you
and um you know not everyone likes to
write with an outline
different processes work for different
people so i think whatever works for you
is great
however i do think that a lot of writers
you know especially if they're just
learning the craft they get
stuck without an outline and so for that
reason i do
teach an outlining class because i think
that
having a strong outline can really help
you make it all the way through to your
finished
first draft right which is which is
where you're going to learn the most it
doesn't
you don't learn as much by starting ten
screenplays as you do by finishing
one screenplay so i do think
having an outline can really help you
make it through the process which is why
i advise doing it if you
don't already have a process that works
for you
i also think that you know the writing
process
is a lot of work and you end up doing
the same amount of work regardless
so to me it's preferable to do the heavy
lifting up front
figure out all of the stuff make all the
mistakes you're going to make with
plotting
in the outlining phase so that you don't
have to
spend all that time writing the script
and then work with
100 pages you're working with five pages
of an outline when you're trying to
rearrange things figure out why your
structure's not working
figure it you know figure out how to
escalate things or whatever it is that
you're doing
do you ever see some of the students do
an outline and realize
i don't like my story yes
i think that that can happen
um but i think it's usually temporary so
um part of the fun of outlining i think
is is actually that you are doing a lot
of the heavy lifting right so you're
thinking
through what are all the details how is
this you know how's the plot going to
progress
what's the character arc what are the
relationships like what are the
you know big set pieces what are the
obstacles all that good stuff so you're
actually doing a lot of the fun
imagining and story creation stuff in
the outlining phase
so i think for that reason it doesn't
happen very often where somebody
outlines
a whole story and then decides they
don't like it enough to write it
i think that when that does happen a lot
of times the problem isn't actually
in having gotten through the outline
itself
the problem is really in the concept so
now that they've seen
what this concept looks like in
you know fully fleshed out into a whole
story then they go
oh that wasn't you know i thought there
was something interesting there
but now it it just it's not delivering
like the entertainment value that i
wanted or whatever
whatever they don't like about it so i
think um if you get to a full outline
and at that point you're feeling
disappointed in your story it might have
something to do with
that initial you know premise that you
came up with
getting a script to someone for fresh
eyes how does a writer know that they're
getting their script to the right person
what if they're getting it to a friend
who's only going to tell them great
things what they want to hear
and then conversely what if they get it
to someone who the writer views is
overly critical
but actually that's the best person to
give it to
yeah i mean you're asking the eternal
question of like
no no it's good um because that is
really confusing right if you've
if you've gone through the whole
struggle of finishing your screenplay
the next question is like who
who do i give it to who reads it um
so i don't necessarily think you think
it's a bad thing if you want to give
your script to somebody who's gonna
give you praise i think that that's okay
that can make you feel good right and
kind of get you over the hump of like
okay now i need to rewrite it
um but i wouldn't rely solely on all
positive reviews um i think the things
to think about maybe when you're having
people read your script for the purpose
of giving you
feedback or notes that you're going to
implement
into your you know into your next draft
um
think about where this person is coming
from in terms of experience how many
scripts they read
um you know because reading a script is
a whole it's a whole
thing that you have to get used to right
like if my mom read a script tomorrow
she would not know what to make of it
she wouldn't have any idea
sort of how to consume a story in this
medium
so someone who has a lot of experience
reading scripts they're just going to
have a better sense of
what's working and not working just
right off the bat i think
um i would be careful that you're not
giving it to someone
who um who doesn't have your
best interests right which can sometimes
be the danger of writer's groups
um not everyone
you want to make sure the person who's
reading your script is wants to help
you get that script where you want it to
be
not where they they want it to be unless
you're unless you're writing for a
producer
so so then you know then you're gonna do
what they're what they want you to do
but um no but if you're just writing a
spec and you're trying to get feedback
on it to improve
the script um you want to make sure that
the people reading it
have experience so that they can
understand how to process
a story in a script and then also that
they um
they want to help you achieve your goal
with the script
versus turning it into what they think
it should be
i think those are probably the two main
things i would say to look out for
and experience doesn't necessarily
equate with
having your best interest yeah that's
definitely true
and that's really sounds like something
that it's going to be case by case
you're just not going to know yeah i
mean
yeah i guess that is
you know hopefully if you're giving to
if you're giving your script to somebody
for a friendly read so it's not
a service that you're paying for or
something like that right if it's just
you know your
friend that you met in writing class and
you want to get notes from them
um hopefully you know them well enough
that you can gauge what kind of
where they're coming from with their
notes right are they going to help you
try to get where you want to be
um and if you don't know that about them
and you give them your script anyway
hopefully you
understand the difference between
notes that are helping you and notes
that are taking you totally away from
your original
vision right and that's a good thing to
think about too
is um distinguishing between those
types of nodes or being able to you have
to be able to
take a note in sort of evaluate
its usefulness to you and then not get
your feelings hurt
and decide decide if you're going to
implement it or not
right and just this is me saying this
not not you but
um also maybe be careful of people too
eager
to take a look at your stuff and hey let
me actually why don't you email me that
because sometimes then you can see that
wow and then you get this feedback and
it's totally
it's it's not only helpful it's
discouraging so sometimes there's like
this
this sheep in or what is it a wolf in
sheep's clothing and you don't totally
realize it
yeah so i think it's just developing a
rapport with someone because you'll
you'll quickly see that yeah and also
another
sort of good you know yardstick to
measure whether you want somebody to
read
um is just talking about them about
movies in general or other screenplays
right because you can gauge somebody's
taste
you can gauge whether you agree with
them on the things that because everyone
has opinions about movies they've seen
like oh the ending of that was terrible
or whatever if you disagree with
everything that they're saying
maybe that's not a person you want to
read your script because clearly you
have a difference
in you know point of view when it comes
to like what makes a good story or what
makes a story work
so i'd say that's something that you can
you know sort of
keep in the back of your mind as a way
to gauge whether someone should read
your material or not
yeah so it sounds like story mechanics
take a long time
to fine-tune and also finding that
person for feedback takes this
the same yeah um and also another thing
you could do is
trade reads right because if you if you
have someone who is
invested in getting good feedback from
you or useful feedback
and um not getting their feelings hurt
then you'll probably have a little bit
more of an even trade there too
right that's a good point yeah
you